the paradigm is driving people the most
which is the performance paradigm to
succeed no one is as seems to be as
interested in the secular scientific
proof that that's good for you so you
know so we're on this rush to sort of
succeed and work 24/7 and make all this
money without any it and it's all on
faith and not only is there no proof
that it's good for us there's actually
more scientific evidence that suggests
that it isn't but when it comes to
meditation then we want the proof so
that it to me is an interesting dynamic
the middle way is an ancient Eastern
philosophy probably first attributed to
the Buddha and that the life story of
the Buddha is really sort of a metaphor
in a way for the middle way and there
are many ways to sort of recount the
middle way but in the context of Pixar I
thought of it I think of it like this
you can imagine perhaps that there are
two people inside of us and so one of
the people inside of us you could think
of as a bureaucrat and the the role of
the bureaucrat is the function is to
function well in the in the world to
make sure we get up on time that we get
to our yeah catch a plane on time to
make sure you know there'll be dinner on
the table at night and we have enough
money in the bank on all of these
requirements that we need in order to be
sort of successful at functioning in the
world and then there's another person
inside of us that you could think of as
like an artist or a free spirit and that
free spirit just wants to live and love
and laugh and create and be and enjoy
and you know and just experience all
that richness and possibilities of life
and what the middle way would say is
that if we get stuck in either one of
those places we subject ourselves to
sort of stress and agitation so that if
everything is about function you know
bureaucracy performance that's all we
care about we might one day kind of wake
up and wonder if we have a truly lift
because we've been so focused on just
getting it right getting it done or you
know whatever it is on the other hand if
we just focused on the artistic side
that
a free-spirited you know part of us then
we might suffer from sort of lack of
momentum we might get frustrated because
we didn't have enough momentum and to
get things done and so what the middle
way is about it's a philosophy of
harmonizing these two things within us
and you know I saw in Pixar a metaphor
for that because it really is a company
that succeeded because it was able to
harmonize these two these two ideas and
it but it turns out that it applies to
you know much more than Pixar I think it
applies to building great organizations
even living living great lives one of
the challenges that we have in terms of
experiential you know feeling good
feeling you know productive feeling good
about who we are on what we do is that
we get stuck in stories it's interesting
it's really interesting actually because
you know at Pixar I was a story company
so I go for a few years at Pixar on a
alone well it's all about story that's
what I learned and then I go off and
study Buddhist philosophy for 10 years
and I come to this scintillating
conclusion that it's all about story why
is that it's because the ideas of these
philosophers now being proven over and
over again by neuroscience says that we
function in a story we have a story in
our minds about what it means you know
to be a man what it means to be a woman
a son a daughter an employee you know we
you we what it means to succeed right we
have this these stories and we get stuck
in them and that stuckness often
produces a lot of stress and agitation
and really the goal of meditation is
that is to open the door so we can go
beyond our stories that's where the
magic is so it's great for calming us
down a little bit you know we get more
control over our Berthe more control
over our mind but it's real potency is
to take us beyond that was those kind of
those kinds of inner limits and so
that's why we recommend like a Juniper
Foundation that the best thing you can
do with meditation is to just do it
regularly like even five minutes a day
because it's about opening opening a
door to
something new